هذا صباح غزه حيث المجزره التي ارتكبتها
قوات الاحتلال بحق عائله ابو حطب وعائله
ابو صلاح في منطقه المواصي حيث تم استهداف
منزل عائله ابو صلاح ادى الى ارتقاء 14
شهيدا في صفوف المواطنين سكان هذا المنزل
مع العلم بان عائله ابو حطب نازحه الى
منزل ابو صلاح للبحث عن الامان والملاذ
الامن في خانيونس في حين ان منطقه المواصي
حددتها قوات الاحتلال بانها منطقه امنه
وطلبت من المواطنين خاصه في الاجزاء
الشرقيه ووسط المحافظه التي تعرض فيها تلك
المناطق الى عمليات توغل وكذلك اطلاق
صواريخ من قبل طائرات الاحتلال طلبت من
المواطنين التوجه الى منطقه المواصي لكن
في منطقه المواصي ايضا لقوا هؤلاء حتفهم
14 شهيدا بين ال 14 هناك تسعه اطفال والله
احنا نايمين تقريبا الساعه 12 ال 5ه في
منطقه قبل المواصف شويه بين المواصف بين
البلد يعني خيام وعرش ونيل وشفنا ضربه
شديده ف صحينا لقينا جر عميقه جدا
وبعض العرش طايره والرمل خش على عرش ثانيه
فاحنا طلع مننا ثلاث شهداء في جبنا ناس من
ضار حطب لهم يومين بس طلع منهم اظن 12
شهيد او 11 شهيد شاردين من الاخلاء بلغوهم
اخل من 112 اخلوا بارض ارض زراعيه لهم غاز
ارض اخلوا فيها لهم خيمه تقويهم من السقعه
والب تيجي الطائرات اسرائيليه تصفهم هم
نائمون باي دم لهم اطفال شكله خطر على
اسرائيل وامريكا الله يكسرك يا اسرائيل
وامريكا صباح دامي وليالي داميه ايضا في
قطاع غزه مع كل ليله ينجل الصباح على
اعداد كبيره من الشهداء ومن الاطفال ال
خاصه ليش
[موسيقى]
طعا المواطنون في هذه اللحظات يستعدون
خاصه اهالي هؤلاء الشهداء في الخارج من
اجل البدء بعمليه تشييع بعد تجهيز وتكفين
هؤلاء الشهداء من قبل العاملين في هذه
المشرحه في مجمع ناصر الطبي وسط حاله من
الحزن الشديد والغضب على هذه المجز التي
تقترفها قوات الاحتلال في كل يوم اللهم
اجرنا ب مصيبتنا واخلفنا خيرا منها انا
لله وانا اليه راجعون حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل الله
[موسيقى]
اكر